what was the first thing that I said
that triggered you
I don't know
I just remember like when you first
started the show and we had some
conversations like when we were in Paris
and you kind of we were like laying it
on me that you were like conservative
you're like testing the water and I was
like oh yeah like you know because I
mean that obviously that never bothered
me I I just because like My Views are
different and I've never seen that as to
me issue I think it was no I think it
was when you um said like women love to
be victims because that's what real that
one really set me off but I get where
you're coming from now yeah it's not
that women like love to be victims they
victimize themselves and they sometimes
I'm not saying all women but some women
will use it as a tool like like to get
what they want